bu
hikaye dinleyip
bu hikaye anlatırken
bu hikaye olmak derece o kendi içsel
yolculuğum da
o zaman zaman bu yoğun tempodan çıkınca
ya Ne oluyor bize ne yapıyorsun Bizi
düşünmeye vakit bulduğum dönemlerden
biriyle 5-6 yıl önce çok geniş bir
açıdan
hayata bakın Player hayatı tanımlayacak
olursak
kendi kişisel not defterime nasıl bir
cümle yazabilirim
bu sanırım hepimizi kapsıyor dünyaya
geliyoruz yani değişik yerlerinde ile ve
konuşamıyoruz Uzunca bir süre bilmiyoruz
hikayeler dinliyoruz sonra konuşma
geçirdiğimiz gelişiyor artık anlatma
işte başlıyor
Ben seni iki
bu ömrümüz artık ne kadar olursa
başlıkta gidiyoruz Dolayısıyla hikaye
alırız hepimizin amacı dedi güzel bir
hikaye olmalı
çok güzel şeyler derdim güzel şeyler
yapmak hatırlanma ya sanki biz annenin
insanlar tarafından değil Mümkünse
birçok insan tarafından hatırlama
İyi seyirler
çok küçük eğitim kurumumuz vardi
doğum günü 6'da haftalık toplantımızı
yaparız ofiste çalışanlar hem de dışında
çalışanları bir araya gelir ve gitmişler
Bir sağa bir toplantı yaparız devamlı da
İngilizlerin her dediğine
muhabbet
arkadaşlar dedi ki 16 grup önemli
Konuşmamız var biliyoruz ama bazılarınız
gelemeyecek çoğumuz gelebilecek Tamam
biz burada da anlatır mısınız bu konuşma
yapar mısınız
ne olur dedi mi benim şimdi prova olur
yani gelebilirsiniz beni almaz
Ben 15 dakika bir daha sürdü beş dakika
en güzel Koleji bu yaptım
Çok teşekkür ederim Selamlar
Bu bir sessizlik ışıkları açtık Evet
arkadaşlar gözüküyor bildirim alalım
ve o ilk konuşan kişinin cesaret her
zaman önemlidir ya o ilk işi konuşmaya
başladı Bir saat 15 dakika geri bildirim
alma
Ya
ben not almakta değil mi oldu konuşma
metni kadar bozalım
daha sonra bana burada
bir şey yapmasaydın verdim olur mu Ne
güzel
yorumlar özleyeceğim kısaca şöyleydi
böyle bir sahipleri Ne var ki o
konuşmayı Aslında ben yapmıyorum şimdi
Ben kendi kendimi anlatmaya geldi mi
davet ettiler ama
arkadaşlarımız şundan bahsetmek lazım şu
olmamış şu görseli çıkarın şöyle olmadı
böyle olmalı ses tuza dikkat edin
ve bir süre sonra durdular Ya biz ne
yapıyoruz 15 dakikada ne kadar
anlatılabilir ki de çok mutlu vardır
bilmiyorum video yayınlanırsa
var burada ne anlattığını görecekler
Dolayısıyla buradan başlamak istedim
için iki olmak çok önemli de çok değerli
geri bildirimler verdiler biraz da
çekiyorlar bazı kelimeleri yanlış
telaffuz etti mi Söyleyeceklerim işte
ekiplerine patronlarının O bir kişilerin
sonra hızlı yerlerde
Eğer şimdi ben biraz bu hikayeden sonra
biraz daha geriye gideceğim sonra
hızlandıracağız ancak burada yaptığımız
paylaşın hikaye anlatmak birkaç hikaye
geçince olacak
ve seri bir şekilde Kendi bestem
uzmanlık alanıyla ilgili ilk peşinde
başlayayım 12-13 yaşındaydı orada Oku
bir ya da iki dil öğretimi de verdim O
konu sanırım tekerlemeler konusu Kara
kara kartallar
ya amca orada kahvaltı geldi ödüyor şu
Herkes bir harften
Bir daha aynı harfle başlayan
kelimelerden oluşan en uzun cümleyi
yazacak Bir kaç gün sonra geleceksin da
sunacak
derse yazdım Kezban kaçtır iki tane
elimi sonra yoğunlaşmaya başladı
kahvaltıdan kelimeler yazıyor koyup için
kuş
Ve Susam geldiğinde o kez bana bir tane
kardeşim duymuştum Kabil Kamile meslek
bulmuştur işte Katil ve mesleğini tercih
almış kanlı kafi falan filan ve su şöyle
birşey oldu bu arada tekrar dediklerini
iPad edilmeli Ah reklamlar
şöyle küçük bir çocuk kaç yaşında
bu Karadeniz kıyısının Kastamonu kentini
kumdere kasabasının kanalı köyünde kalan
kanlı katil Kezban
bu kaynanasının Köyü Kuzey kesimindeki
kocaman kayalıkları kurgu konağını
kapısının kilidini kırarak kaçtı
Evet
efendim yani gidiyorlar kendi otobüs
aklıyla takdir bekliyorum
Bekliyorum işte işsizlik ve benzeri
sessizlik
var
yani detaylar mıyım hayatım yaşadım
çünkü bu yolu biliyorsunuz
nasıl fark edeceksiniz
neyse o önemli değil önemli
olan ilgili
keşfettim birazcık
mı Ondan sonra yeteneğin varsa zaman
içerisinde geliştirmeye çalıştım daha
sonra atıyorum kısımlarını üniversiteden
mezun oldu Orta Doğu Teknik Üniversitesi
İngilizce Öğretmenliği
1098 haziran'ında benzin olduğum Temmuza
gitmem aldım bir ay sonra başka bir özel
üniversitede Başkent Üniversitesinde
öğretim örüyoruz gönderi alışmak o kadar
zordu ki ve daha sonra gitmiyorum alalım
tenefüslerde ofislere çık
öğrencilerle beraber kendine gitmiyor
çünkü daha alışamadım ben kendim
öğrencisiydim
Neyse başladık anlatmaya
öğrenciler Türkiye'nin her tarafından ve
orada İngilizce öğreniminde ki sorunları
yavaş yavaş gerçekle başladı dedi not
aldım çözmeye çalıştım buldum dedim
süperim dedim Sonra içerisine başka bir
öğrenci grubunda
olduğum şeyi çalışıyorum adı biliyor
duygusu devamlı daha o günleri Yeditepe
Üniversitesi Bilgi Üniversitesi 8 Yüzyıl
bu
çalışmayı işte onlar da sonrada
okul diye bir durumda kurduk Toplamda 4
bin 500 tane
İngilizce öğrenmek isteyen insanlar
yakından çalışmayla olur bu 4500 ün son
56 yıllık bölümde ise 1500 tanesi
İstanbul'daki çeşitli üniversitelerde
okuyan Üniversite öğrencileri hazırlık
sınıflarında sorun yaşamışlar
Dolayısıyla ay var mı de parmak verin
kim hazırlık sınıfında sonra yaşadı
Bu arkadaşların paralarını alamadık Evet
geçmiş herhalde o
38 103-105 yıl İngilizce öğrenme süreci
içerisinde olan insanlar var hatta
bazılarını oluyor o da hadi gelin Çünkü
bile damga vurmuşlar İngilizce gideyim
ABC yok
8'de gidip bir 10 gün konuşma eğitim
alabilir mi olur Niye
iş görüşmesi vardı yapacağız Ben
konuşmuyorum mevzu ama konuşamıyorum
üzerinde öğrenci arkadaşımızla
çalışmalar yaptık
bir
çözüm geliştirme yükle ağzına bir
projeye dönüştü ilerleyen beş dakika
boyunca hızlı bir şekilde anlatacağım
zaten eğer sorun oldu büyük sorunu
çözebilen bir problem da en sevilen bir
çözüm de arada Peki ama çözümün parçası
olabilecek Çok etkili ve etki alanında
geliştirebilecek çok önemli bir çözüm
şimdi
yeni
başlamış dünya genelinde an itibariyle
iki binden fazla insan İngilizce öğrenme
ihtiyacı hissetmekte ya da İngilizce
öğrenme isteği
12 milyardan fazla insan çok büyük bir
sayı Ülkeden ülkeye İngilizce
öğrenmelerini değişiklik gösterse de
daha fazla Ortak ortak sendromlar vardır
mesela buradan başlayalım kaç kişi
ingilizce biliyorum diyelim parmak
alırsın yani ingilizce biliyorum demek
Clash hop Şu an sizin anlattıklarınız
hepsini çıkıp Ben de kendi alanında
anlatabilirim kaç kişi göreyim O bayağı
var Tamam kaç kişi orta düzey İngilizce
biliyorum indirmeniz düzenlenebileceği
biliyorum kaç kişi daha yeni başladım
Ama halledeceğim o zaman başladı yüksek
sesle Hakan Bey de olduğu gibi bunun
izleyeceksiniz bir güç biraz daha yüksek
mi Evet yüksek sesle devam
bu
süper ama ama ama
devam et evet bu geri alıyoruz
abone ol
mi
Evet hazırız yeni geliyor
çok güzel mi
mi Evet
abone ol
en güzel sonucu su
Vay vay vay
vay vay vay
kamera var mı Ona bakın Evet var ya sen
ayrı girmiş durumdayız hep toplum olarak
hem de dünyanın hatırı sayılır sayıda
ülkesinde durum çok kötü
bugün yaşadığımız bu
kendini ifade biz
ne
dolduracaksın
sıkıntılardan biri yani Sonundaki
sorumlu büyük sonundaki temel
sıkıntılardan Biri bulur
insanlar yeteri kadar kendi ve
öğrenmeden Bir de bir beceriye sahip
olmalı
ve o böceğin kullanmak yaşam kalitesini
artırmak
bu gece
İngilizcesi olanlar bakalım gideceğim
ve
işsizlik oranı yüksek sesle İngilizce
işsizlik oranı var mı
mi Evet hava kirliliği
çok güzel
Bu bir daha yazmadım oranları
çok güzel almışlar devam ediyoruz
konuşuyorum
çok
güzel Bilmem koltuk
abone ol
çok güzel olacaklar bir sürü üzüldü ama
daha fazla
kalemimden önce bitti
da bitti
şimdi Birazda serseri geçeceğiz çarpıp
iyi geçmedi
yani eşya
işsizlik oranları artıyor
ama bir şey kokuların ona söyleyeceğimi
bilemiyorum şöyle bir şey olabilir mi
yani biz neden ikinci bitki öğrenirken
böyle garip geçiyoruz
neden o şeyi sıralamayı atmıyoruz Çünkü
çok
zor çok zordur Böyle basit bir göremeden
bir problem daha karmaşık bir hale
gelmişse
sonra artık ya Bu kadar büyüklük Bu
kadar basit bir çözümü olamaz değil hiç
kimse dönüp bakmaz basit çözümleri bu Ee
tabii bu Mesleki açıdan
yaşadığınız sorunu ister istemez sizde
sizde büyük bir bir enerji patlamalık ya
Ne yapıyorsunuz ya bana katkı sağlamamız
lazım şu yapmam lazım bunu yapmam lazım
diye
çok
güzel Pro yaptıran ödeyeceğim dedi
Biz birazdan izleyeceğiniz 2'den alıp
bir video dakikalık bir video
proje
kısaca anlatmak için
hazırladığımız bir video basit bir
öğrenme sürecini ikinci dil öğreniminde
İnsanların karşısına soğan 1 hafta
bu
arasında Bana en çok sorulan Bana en çok
önem soru şuydu koca bir öğrenmek biraz
da sanki yetenek misiniz Ben de Muhammed
evde
görebilirsiniz
sanki biraz yaptığımız meselesi Hayır
bir öğrenmek Kesinlikle değil
dünyanın kelimelerle sağlar en az bir
dil konuşabiliyor ama seni konuşalım
şimdi ben çocuk 0'dan 6'ya kadar sürekli
dışarıdan içeri kokuyor içerik içerik
içerik ve Okula başlamadan da alfabeyi
öğrenmemiş yazma okuma bilmiyorum ama
konuş bu Türkiye konuşuyor konuşuyor
aynı ikiniz için de geçerli yetenek
meselesi değil sadece yeteri kadar
içerikle karşılaşma 81 öğrenmek
kullanabilmek sırası tamam mı çıkacaksın
olacağız şimdi
böyle bir şey yok Şimdi bir de
abone ol
bu Ercan Usta oynuyorlar
ama biz amca
bu ispat uyumayacağım ağrısı bu değişim
abla
ne olur
abone ol
bu
içinde o
böyle olsun
3D
Yok kız o
iki şimdi fırsatınız breakfast yeterli
mi
abone ol
abone ol abone ol
yok artık
Yok yok euro
bu bayram ve santral organize olmaz
ayport hileler mantı problem
abone ol
bu
Kars hava durumu ne
O da şimdi burda Evet şimdi geldik
22'den oku
da açabiliriz
abone ol
şu duvardaki katalım güzel tavsiye
edilir Ee
16 başkası yılı aşkın bir süre bir
kişiyle başlayan şu an itibariyle 47
kişinin fultaym artık parkta katkı yaptı
bünyesinde İngiliz Amerikalı
arkadaşlarımızın da olduğu dünya
genelinde 1.6 milyon insanın ziyaret
ettiği 200 bin kişi 199 gün sürdü Bu
seansta zorluklardan 200 bin kişinin
yoğun olduğu ve düzenli olarak
kullanmaya çalıştığı kullandığı kocaman
bir
okuyoruz İngilizce öğrenme sürecinin bir
havuzda doldu Türkçe öğrenme süreci bir
Havuzun dolmasını benzetecek olursak
aynı şekilde için de geçerli olduğu
zaman Paşa gidene kadar biri aldığımız
zaman doğal olarak biz konuşacağız ya da
yazacağız aynı şeyi Biz için de geçerli
biz bu o Platformu hayran geliştirmeye
devam ediyoruz 16 ana dil desteğiyle
bu platformda ben o
birkaç şey ekleyip gelecek olacak gibi
kusura bakmayın
Bu çok güzel bir duygu
Türkiye'de büyük çoğunluğu Türk
mühendislerinin de dilbilimcilerin bir
araya gelerek yaptı ve Diş ve Konya'da
30000 civarında insan kullanıyor ve
ortalaması Türkiye'den çok çok yukarıda
günü 22 dakika vakit Avcılar Rusya'da Ya
insanların ince gündüz bu platforma
girip anadillerini Rusya seçerek
İngilizce'de geliştirmede bilmek çok
güzel bir duygu Ee dünyanın en büyük
sorunlarından biri
bu adaletsiz gelir dağılımı küre serbest
oldu adaletsiz Gelir gelir dağılımının
olarak başka sorunlara yol açıyor
eğitimde fırsat eşitsizliği o strip Bu
yönüyle buna çok ciddi bir katkı sağlar
küresel kaynak tasarrufu sağlar ara
Kağıt zaman enerji ne dersiniz değil be
Osis thrill sadece İngilizce ile ilgili
bir şey öğrettiği ile ilgili bir şey
öğrenme değil aynı zamanda İngilizce
dilini öğrenerek yeni bilgiler
edinmemizi sağlar burada yaşayan bir
kişi iki yıl sonra kendisini bu muhteşem
bir genel gördüğümde olur çünkü burada
küçük kesitler var bu kesitlerin
alındığı kaynakları yönlendirme ile
ilgili var Dolayısıyla ilgi alanlarıyla
ilgili dinlemeler okumaları yapar e ve
en önemlisi paylaşım kültürüne katkı
basiti
paylaşılanların paylaşıldı kocaman bir
okyanusu'nda hangi amaçla olursa olsun
ister bilgileri sevilen gelsin kullanıcı
bu prensibi ile kendisini
geliştirebilecek bir alan mutlaka
bulabilir şuradan bitmez görüntüyü
e paylaşım kötü değil kültürü paylaşıp
kültürü ve medeniyetinin insanlığın
gelişmesi sağlanır kültür bunun için iki
tane temel özelliği ihtiyaç var
birincisi
bu Burada gördüğünüz gibi hayal etmek
çok önemlidir biraz da tehlikeli
olabilir çocuklarımız Sadece bu tür
masallarla bir türlü tehlikeli olabilir
Biz kendi kültürümüzde davranacak Ya bu
çok kullanıyoruz işte bir gün çıksa da
şöyle olsa olsa bundan sonra hayatımın
süper olacak Birlikte çalışmak Hayal
kurduk hayalimizi geliştirmek için
gerçekleştirmek için çalışacağız çok
çalışacağız Çok çalışmalıyız ve bu
ikisinin birleşimi bizim hayatta kalma
hedeflerimizi ulaştıktan sonra değişim
yaratmak yaşam kalitemizi yükseltmek
için yapmak istediğimiz şeyler de
olmazsa olmaz Eğer kuracağız ve çok
çalışacağız bir Japon atasözü söyle
ya hiçbirimiz
bu hepimizde daha akıllı olamayız
bu örnekleri çoğaltalım Hiçbirimiz
hepimizden daha Çalışkan olmayız daha
üretken daha faydalı olamayız
şu dünyadaki diğer bezeleri baktığımızda
da bir tane sıfatta kullanacak olursak
Ama hiçbiriniz
o bizden daha güzel olalım teşekkürler